[Music]
welcome welcome and back brian we
switched over to the touch network here
we are on the minus touch network if
you're joining us uh let's turn let's
turn twitter off here
i think i can get rid of that thing
maybe maybe not i don't know
oh my gosh
there we go there we go
i'm just trying to there we go okay
there we go okay so we're off twitter
we're on the midas touch network
uh here on the mind of touch youtube
channel thanks for joining us if you're
just tuning in we have some coverage
that we want to share with you here on
the midas touch network um gabe can you
copy that link and send it over to them
so they have that link so they can start
uh spreading that around the interwebs
the the youtube link can you do that for
me yes i can on the midas touch uh yeah
put that over there so they have that
that link um we are going to be holding
the remarks from the president of the
united states joe biden about
the
uh student debt relief program that he
is going to release today uh it sounds
like that they're going to be delivering
the marks at the bottom of the hour i'm
not sure
exactly how long those remarks are going
to be we'll probably stick around
through this hour we're going to have
commentary coming in me and gabe are
going to provide commentary as best we
can we also
are going to be joined i think by the
midas touch the mizellas brothers
possibly ben possibly brett i don't know
if jordy's feeling well enough to uh to
join us but they're going to be joining
us here on the midas touch network
welcome welcome welcome everyone to our
special coverage of the remarks uh for
for joe biden
uh president joe biden
uh as he
as he's going to
uh give remarks about the student debt
relief today um i am tony michaels this
is my co-host and executive producer
gabe sanchez hello so we're live here on
the midas touch network excuse me we had
to do this on the fly yeah when you do
live things like live streaming and
stuff you kind of got to do it on the
fly so we're trying to put it together
here um yeah there's he's asking about
yeah he wants can you can you make him a
thumbnail to get it up there yeah after
you told me no you don't need to well i
i mean it's gonna put one up is what i
meant yeah yeah yeah it's gonna put one
up i'll switch it house but i mean but i
mean it it kind of goes with what's
happening i don't know it says brandon
cancels debt so i mean that's you know
yeah well i gotta change it which means
it changes it for everything right
no no no just just send it over here
i'll i'll change it i can do it on my
end yeah yeah
yeah but it's the same broadcast the one
from this morning
no
right but no but if you change it just
on that channel
just at the top just on that youtube
it'll change it there
only change it there you just go to edit
and that will change but don't turn it
off because then oh man then we'll lose
that yeah don't screw it up gabe or you
can send it over yeah i'll just send you
the suits send it to the suits and yeah
they'll take care of it over there so um
but if they if they want to send that
link around i'm gonna get um again see
we're all on the fly here and and if
anyone knows we actually host the show
and we actually
um we're producing the show as we're
going so if it seems like we're working
and talking at the same time that's
exactly what we're doing
so let's let's put that there add banner
let's see
there we go see there we go live
president madden announced historic
student loan relief here on the midas
touch network thank you for joining us
thanks for everyone sticking around uh
for the live coverage
of president biden delivering remarks on
the student
loan relief program that is historic i i
want i want to tell everyone who's
joining us
that i brought up this this morning that
there is going to be a very stark
contrast a very stark contrast today
between
uh in our history the president united
states joe biden is going to come out
and he's going to deliver a promise to
the american working class he's going to
make sure and then that they actually
have debt relief in the form of their
student debt relief i believe that's
very important and it's contrasted by
the former guy
down in florida who gets basically he
gets rejected by a federal judge because
he kind of wrote this order half-ass
himself he's representing himself pretty
much and also he filed it with the wrong
court she knows
she knows he found it with the wrong
court and that is the contrast here you
have a president of a party who is
pro-democracy who is delivering for the
american people just as he promised he
would do
um it's not really that far off from
what he said he would do on the campaign
trail gabe it's not even that far no i
mean it is exactly what he said he said
he would do ten thousand he would also
like to say you it would also like
community colleges to be free for people
to attend you know he never promised a
50k he said when he answered the
question no i will not uh i will not
forgive 50k
um so people need to understand kind of
where those things lay out but he did
make a promise during the campaign trail
for 10k and he did that and went beyond
that for those who have pell grants and
went up to 20 dollars so he delivered on
his promise and added more to what was
done
right um kim i'm gonna sell let's see i
think we should pull the
let's see here let me share my screen i
want to pull that graphic of what you're
talking about there
um of because i i think that is getting
a little confused uh some people are
getting confused about what what is
actually uh happening with this program
this is actually the white house's copy
of their document this morning that
they're putting out for this program
for giving the debt 20 000 if you went
to college on pell grants and then 10
000 if you didn't receive pell grants
um just don't okay he's got he's going
there so i'm going to see if they're
going to join us but
gabe now you have personally
personally you're going to see some of
the benefits from this so tell us i'm
not oh you ha you're not going no no no
i'm not going to well here so for full
context like
i am uh or i was the recipient of pell
grants okay i was in school i received
pell grants because my family did not
make enough money um
you know we well actually the way where
our household income was we were
eligible for the recipient of a pell
grant or pell grants
i over time have paid those off
um
and i wish
uh i wish i was i wish i would have been
on the receiving end however i'm not and
i am super grateful
and i'm super happy for those right now
who are able to receive those benefits
of getting 10 to 20 000
removed from their loans and being
forgiven
um
it is something that i feel like it is a
rising tide that will lift all boats in
this scenario it is something it's not
injecting money into the economy it is
it is it is cutting costs for those
people who need it right now right you
know we we talked about it on the show
earlier today which is 59 of americans
which is 81 of republicans believe that
this will cause an increase in inflation
which that is not the case here right
just the understanding in the
fundamental economics economy
fundamental
of economics in our country right now is
reducing and cutting the costs of
of
the the loans that you took out as a
student will not add to the inflation
problem right we are saving money that
will allow people to spend it on car
payments their rent their mortgage food
their children like these are things
that will help go into the economy and
actually boost
what's what we have going on so i as a
recipient of pell grants super grateful
for getting them
uh and and i am super happy and grateful
for those who are receiving the benefits
of those cost reductions
when it comes to their own because
that's what it is that's what it is it's
not a payment it's a cost right of that
and the people that say oh i want a
credit for the things that i paid off i
say no no no no no no no you paid it off
yes
it was hard work and you did it and i
did it as well
but
again we should be hoping for the best
for those within our own generation and
those generations that are before and
after us
and what i mean by that as i say that
those people
we should be hoping that we make it
easier for them to attend college
to pay off their loans to make it easier
to to continue education right and so
when i say that right now i'm just i i'm
i'm very happy because again we talked
on our show earlier today biden didn't
need to do this right the economy is
doing well he didn't have to say oh well
you know what
er you don't really need it right now
right this is we have record low
unemployment you guys get jobs you can
afford your student loans pull yourself
up by your bootstraps type stuff right
right and i personally had to refinance
my student loans twice in order to pay
them off
and so it wasn't an easy thing at all
and i don't wish that on anyone right
because
the price of the cost of tuition has has
increased exponentially over the the uh
the inflation rate that we have right
it's something that is just
insane especially for private
institutions
and the cost of attending versus what
you're getting on on the receiving end
as a result of your education
and so
this is something that will greatly
benefit not only the people who are
getting those cost reductions by getting
10 to 20k for given but also the people
that will then will receive that money
because they're deciding to then take
those savings and spend it elsewhere in
the economy so this is one of those
things that say
it does have a lasting effect on more
than just the person who is receiving
the loan forgiveness and i think a lot
of people are like oh a little very
selfish one-sided because like oh well
you're getting forgiven alone why wasn't
i forgiven alone right well look you had
republicans in here have been talking
about
all these other things to to help your
to help you as as a
as a us citizen right as someone and
it's just not
it is not something they want to do
democrats are the only ones are willing
to go through and we've seen that in the
last month
under biden right
uh pact act chips act the inflation act
uh right now reducing
the or the helping student loans with
her with their student loan forgiveness
this is something that only only
democrats
have offered to do republicans have
stood by in an anti-american policy and
said we won't help you
we won't we won't help you in any way
that makes your life easier as an
american living in this country so
this is you know as someone who was a
recipient of pell grants and who did
have to refinance and who did have to
pay off loans
i am
so happy for those people who are now
going to be getting the the aid that
they have right now
well
and and i i am someone who paid off my
loans um again i didn't carry my loans
very long because
because i actually i i'm a college
dropout and that and that i think is um
some of the people who are mad because
they did pay off their loans um
and people who have worked hard to pay
off their loans i worked hard to pay off
what was remaining on my loans right
years ago but i'm not mad because the
american people and the american working
class are receiving a cost reduction
which is going to i don't know help the
american working class and i think
that's important uh we have brett
manziel's with us brett what do you make
of what do you make of this development
where the president's going to come out
and speak to us today
oh i mean let's be real here this is the
largest student loan relief that we've
ever seen in american history and so i
think we need to be cognizant of that
fact and this is going to help so many
americans and i believe like 90 plus
percent of the relief is going to be to
people earning less than 75 000 a year
so this is going to disproportionately
help the people who need it most which i
think is great i think it's funny to see
the antibody response from republicans
anytime a policy is presented that is
something that actually helps people
instead of major businesses billionaires
things like that it's like you could
give all the relief all the tax cuts all
the bailouts to businesses and
billionaires in the world and
republicans cheered on but the second
you decide to give a single bit of
relief to the average american all of a
sudden it's oh this is going to cause
inflation this is going to cause all
these problems it's like they are just
so afraid to help regular americans and
i think they realize that once people
start to feel the effects of this
they're going to be like oh this is
great actually this is really good and
really helpful and all these attacks on
biden about socialism or whatever are
just ridiculous i mean let's face it the
system is extremely broken i'm curious
to hear the details of this plan when
president biden lays them out because
what i don't want is i don't want to see
a temporary benefit you know that all of
a sudden next year we still have the
same problems and it just keeps going on
and on and on so what i want to learn
and dig deeper on um is how is this
going to not just be a band-aid on the
wound but how is this actually going to
heal the wound going forward and allow
this not to happen again and again and
put people in this cycle because
what it does is when people are saddled
with this student loan debt they're not
able to take the risks that are
necessary for them to really go out
there and succeed they're not able to
be entrepreneurial in many aspects
they're not able to take chances on
careers and they just don't have that
that safety net and it's really because
there's a system that is
very predatory on on people who are
making decisions at times when let's
face it i mean do you know everything
about life when you're like 18 years old
and are trying to make your your future
decisions so it's it's extremely
predatory and i think at minimum we got
to get rid of all this interest that's
been stacking up and and to me i think
you know and i want to hear the details
of the plan to see exactly what it does
but you know if if you owe 20 000 on
your loans and you paid twenty thousand
dollars to interest i think that should
just go and apply straight to your
principal um i i don't think people
should be making exorbitant amounts of
money off struggling students who
who need help and are just trying to
to better their lives here because
that's the other thing too is like you
know as as someone who took out student
loans right both pell and and private
loans like it is one of those things
that really come to get you which is
like where do you sit is it you know
variable interest fixed interest like
how high are those interest rates you
know especially as you come out of
college like oh shoot like i should you
know knowing or maybe not knowing too is
like which one should i be paying off
first right you're like oh i got to make
sure that i pay off the highest interest
one first but yeah like how do i how do
i cut costs and and save money so that i
can apply more do i have to refinance
like
in and of itself like inherently the
higher education system is flawed it is
broken in the way in which we price it
in a way in which you get benefit of
your education yeah um
and as you said the predatory factor of
like private banking institutions
giving you money and signing like you
know
i as an 18 year old can take out this
amount of money
at a high interest rate to pay for
college but i don't have certain rights
elsewhere like it doesn't make a lot of
sense and so right now this ten to
twenty thousand dollars is an amazingly
uh
big accomplishment for the biden
administration and everyone who will
receive those savings but also it is
something where it's like well we should
it is something that we need to look at
as the overall higher education
continuing education
sector to say like how can we benefit so
next generation and the next classes
that come through these schools
aren't
uh aren't uh victims of the same problem
right we're like fixing something right
now but then continuing on past this how
are we going to help those who want to
get an education and who want and need
to get those loans uh down the line
i just want to bring up a an article
from october of 2020 that you won't see
any republicans referencing today and
it's about how lenders forgave 287
million dollars in unpaid debt by donald
trump and you never heard anyone blink
an eye when donald trump's debt was
forgiven they a quote unquote
billionaire's debt was forgiven to the
tune of 287 million dollars and you can
look that up and market watch it's
reported all over the place and you
forget how people and especially people
close to trump took advantage of that
ppp loan program at the beginning of the
pandemic and really just took all of our
money uh didn't have to pay back those
loans and basically scammed the american
public out of millions and millions and
millions of dollars and nobody batted an
eye at that so i think all all relief is
good but i want to make sure that we're
you know helping those underlying issues
like you said gabe so that going forward
that this isn't a a recurring issue that
we have and i think also like hey you
got to look at things like times change
things change because somebody's doing
something good now um
you know you can't be that selfish to
not want people to succeed now because
you may have not have had that
opportunity i mean think about like
advancements in
in medicine and things like that like
yes i'm sure there are a lot of people
who
you know when certain uh
treatments came out for certain kinds of
cancers and and whatnot there were
people who felt like you know if only i
had this you know 10 years ago but does
that mean everyone right now deserves to
die no i think
it's it's great and we should be helping
all these people with everything we can
and the fact that president biden is
taking an action like you said gabe that
he really doesn't have to do but that he
wants to uphold this promise that he
made during the campaign and he's doing
what we can i think we need to look at
that and and say hey we're moving the
ball forward here and that's a good
thing well i think the context of this
is great like you said because we can
even go back to other campaigns of
presidential campaigns that's having
said that
joe biden is going to try to uh deliver
on his promise that he gave the american
people in 2020 because we have to we
have to give it that context right
because you remember when mitt romney
was like oh if you want to go to college
just borrow a million dollars from your
parents right like if you want to start
a business just borrow a million bucks
you know yeah because every parent has a
million dollars their parents right i
mean we have we have this uh situation
um where
during the pandemic i think the american
people learned a lot about ourselves but
more than anything they learned about
our system of government and they
learned about our society and our
culture because there was a lot of
people who who struggled to even afford
college
who were called essential workers and
said nope you have to work you have to
work during a pandemic and there were
other folks who weren't allowed to work
during the pandemic and they discovered
that the government could save their the
business
that they worked for they would save
them i mean they gave him uh you know
some crumbs right you know 800 bucks or
whatever it was to get through the next
eight or nine months
but then when the democrats came in
march of 2021 and actually delivered a
package of cobid relief that was for the
american people i think people
discovered hey
our labor is something that we actually
barter with and
and
we actually can't afford to give the
american working class
actual benefits inside of our government
because it's ours it's our country it's
our government we don't have to cater to
the billionaires who want to wipe away
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
debt we can actually do that for
i don't know the american working class
and i think that is the most important
component of this is that in this moment
when joe biden could say look we have
record low unemployment wages are on
their way up the stock market's up the
economy there's high demand in the
economy i don't think it's a good time
to really be
lowering the cost on americans at this
point and spending feder spending
quote-unquote federal dollars
on this forgiveness of these loans he
absolutely could say that he could
renege on his on his
campaign promise turn tail and run
easily but he's not because i truly
believe with the infrastructure bill
with the pact act with the chips bill um
with
what what he wanted with billback better
which became the
inflation reduction act with the covid
relief and now with this movement on the
student let student loan debt plan
joe biden his number one concern is the
american people it is the american
working class and his aim is to deliver
for them um i believe he couldn't be
doing more with what he's got tony right
really i mean he is betting he is
betting on america right you've got the
chips act which is trying to make our
country an actual person or actual
entity that will compete against someone
who is uh overseas right we want to
bring those jobs to america the thing
that republicans have said they would do
over and over again we'll give you a
credit we'll give you a tax credit if
you keep jobs here and they go well
actually i can make i can save more
money if i send them overseas right it's
made in america or you know as much as
trump wants to say it's always made in
china for him or some other country that
isn't america
uh well all of his products are to be
fair so that's right exactly looking at
it through that length i mean let's just
be real about how out of touch these
people are i mean you still have mitch
mcconnell to this day making statements
saying that americans are still
living off the paychecks they received
in the coveted relief act he believes
that people are still living off the
twelve hundred dollar checks the six
thousand subjects i mean that is if you
really think that an average american is
surviving on 600 for over a year or over
really the course of a week or two like
like that is so out of touch and that's
what they think of the american people
they just want to throw them crumbs
while they're getting billions and
billions of dollars in their corrupt
relationships and everything that
they're doing and nobody calls them out
on it so we got to call him out on it
but i mean i want to point you to this
brian tyler cohen post which over which
has a nice overview of a lot of those
accomplishments we were talking about
10k in student loan debt limited up to
20k actually the inflation reduction act
which is also remember the biggest
climate bill in all of history the
american rescue plan infrastructure the
biggest gun reform package that we have
seen in decades chips the packed act the
most jobs added lowest unemployment in
50 years we got rid of the al-qaeda
leader and now let's look at the
republican platform who just says no to
everything no to everything for the
american people but then they throw on a
little sprinkles of fascism there so
what they want to do as well is defund
the fbi dissolve the justice department
they want to prevent sick veterans from
getting health care they want to
eliminate your social security and
medicare they want to force 10 year olds
to carry their rapist baby to term they
want to lock up dr fauci they want to
ban and burn books i mean the two
parties aren't even remotely similar
here and so i think that's important as
we head into the midterms with this
renewed energy to understand the stakes
and understand what republicans are
trying to do they're trying to take away
your freedoms they're trying to take
away everything that we have fought for
in this country and they try to house it
in this term woke which really just
means to actually be aware to injustices
and to want the world to be a better
more equal place ask them to define it
they can't honestly without sounding
incredibly racist because because that's
the
every everything that they have brought
forward is anti-american right they do
not want to cross the aisle and help any
american when it comes to democratic
policies and bettering their their lives
and those that you know they care for
right they are unwilling
to to bring jobs to america they are
unwilling to
help out people who have loans they're
unwilling to
uh to help with health care i mean these
are the infrastructure in which our
country is built on
they are unwilling to do anything that
is pro-american these patriots the
people that say they are pro-america and
they're patriotic and they will live and
die and these colors don't bleed
[ __ ] these republicans will take any
money they can from lobbyists and they
will screw over the constituents that
they were elected to represent and they
will not do anything they will abandon
them and take whatever money they can
financial incentive and say for those
people that elected them yeah good luck
no i'm not gonna really care about you
and that's what it is at the core i mean
even you brought up the loans that were
forgiven for trump you look at the loans
the the bailouts that were done for
banks uh the airline industry and even
despite them saying do not do stock
buybacks they said okay we won't and
then did stock buybacks and they said we
need more money and when asked where did
the money go that we told you not to use
for stock buybacks they said well we did
it for stock buybacks no penalties ceos
and and corporate execs get uh golden
parachutes and handcuffs they're
no problem no problem whatsoever with
those people from the republican party
and somebody astutely pointed out in the
comments also don't forget the trillions
of dollars in tax cuts that donald trump
gave to the rich right once again no
issues there and by the way like biden
is crushing it on the debt and the
deficit like biden is lowering the debt
lowering the deficit democrats always do
they always do this is this this is a
continuing narrative in this country
republicans always put us economically
in a rough situation they always do and
because they're not looking out for the
actual people in this country biden
trust the american people i think that's
really what this tell is today because
as we're waiting here i want to give
everyone context we're waiting uh for
president biden to make his remarks here
at the white house now on this student
debt uh relief program that he's going
to be talking about today for anyone
listening and
joining us now we're going to be soon
going to the white house here
for these remarks from the from
president biden but i really think that
people they forget about that all the
time is that republicans destroy
everything look at any charge look at
any graph any charge just look at the
raw numbers it all shows there and by
the way we did an ad about this but
donald trump before he became president
even said that the democrats are better
uh for the economy before he decided to
become a republican and run and pull one
over and destroy the economy and destroy
the economy
the republican party
stands on this christian
platform right and remember christians
uh you know what what what did the
christians say about forgiveness i heard
something about forgiveness right right
you know it's like you know i will house
i will care for the sick i will help you
out in any ways that i can because i
will care for you as a fellow human
being not just a christian are they
really christians are they but they're
not but they're not so you know if we
talk about forgiveness they are willing
to forgive their own sins
to which they play victim for
and unwilling to help or forgive those
who actually need it i mean here's the
problem could anybody genuinely say this
is fair can anybody say it's fair where
say you have to take out 50 000 in loans
for college and many people are taking
out much more than that but then when
you pay it back you pay back your 50k
and you've barely even paid towards your
principal oh yeah because all your money
has gone to interest is that fair is
that fair
is it fair to take out a 50 000 loan and
ultimately you're end up paying over the
course of your life on 150k 200k for
that 50k i mean that's just [ __ ] and
i think most americans understand that
that's [ __ ] understand that that's
an unfair system that's stacked against
them that's just making other people
wealthy at their expense at them and
it's preventing them from being able to
live their dreams and and pursue all
their ambitions and and whatnot and uh
you know it's it's garbage but i think
you know as we see the polls kind of
shift we saw a reuters poll today show
that president biden's ratings were
higher than they've been since before
the summer well and also the new year
the new york 19th yeah and i think
you're seeing this i think you're
basically seeing now that i'll call it
the coalition of the normal i think it's
the coalition of people who by the way
may not be on the right or may not be on
the left when it comes to a lot of these
issues but they see just common sense
policies and the democrats are the ones
right now pursuing just common sense
policies like if republicans could try
going to like a gun violence issue for
example republicans could try to act
like oh spooky scary democrats are
trying to take your guns the center of
the country the the middle of the
country most americans something like 75
80 percent of americans actually want
common sense restrictions on guns they
want gun safety reform i mean that's not
a radical issue so i think you're
getting all these people who are kind of
more
center-minded but in our country
center-minded happens to be what
republicans think of as the far left but
people who want to have well it's
radical bread radical very radical
radical to have health care it's radical
to be able to afford to pay for college
it's radical to be able to get insulin
at an affordable price it's radical to
be able to get cancer treatment if
you're a veteran who served our country
and i think we have americans
across the country right now being like
that [ __ ] doesn't sound very radical to
me actually that sounds like stuff i'm
i'm i'm pretty into so as a result
you're seeing people come out in waves
like in the new york 19 election where
you have a republican trying to hammer
home you know inflation inflation
inflation you know these economic issues
that people realize are global issues
that have been getting better each and
every month as the economy is doing
blockbuster jobs numbers and whatnot and
then you have the democrat who very
early on made the core of their campaign
this notion of republicans want to take
away your rights and abortion is a key
issue and most americans want to not be
restricted have these crazy complete
abortion bans whereby the government is
mandating what you can do with your body
and so those things are resonating
people are waking up we saw it in kansas
we saw it in new york 19 and i think
we're going to see a huge blue wave in
november i and it's going to take all of
us but the reason i'm saying it is not
to say oh we could sit home and relax no
no i want you to be energized we got a
lot i want you to be excited we got to
lean into it we got to be ready and we
got to be pumped up and we got to get
everybody as excited as we are about
these results and everybody is
passionate to push back against this
authoritarianism that is coming our way
because without it you know it's it's on
us at the end of the day to spread these
messages we've already seen what kind of
the corporate media does and how they
handle joe biden's accomplishments but
we're pushing we're defying the odds
against that that race last night in new
york 19 there were some polls that had
the republican up by as much as 10
points right they had that as a lean r
district now think about that every time
you go on 538 or real real clear
politics or whatever website you use to
look at the aggregation of polls all
those districts that are lean are by a
few points by plus five plus six guess
what [ __ ] it doesn't matter it's not
taking into account rovember which is
what we call it here rovember row row
row your vote we are coming for this we
are going to protect our freedoms and
the freedoms of all freedom loving
americans well i i think that's a great
point because follow the minus touch
network while you're here subscribe if
you're if you're listening you're not
going to want to miss a thing because i
think democrats have a better messaging
platform and i don't want to pat
ourselves in the back here at the minus
touch network and i mean you you brett
and ben and jordy have done such a great
job at delivering some of the messaging
for the country to really understand hey
it it is about messaging it is about
politics you do have to do this thing
and go out to win elections you have to
fight back a little bit inside this
world where
if you want to set policy you're gonna
have to win places like the new york
19th that is a place where you can win
and you should win and that is i think
the most important thing is to get the
messaging out because community is
important and i think that's why beto is
doing so well in texas it's because he's
not talking he's not talking about
people's genitalia in bathrooms he's
talking about texans he's talking about
what's important to them like you said
not to go broke because of a damn
medical bill yeah i mean your kid's
worry that they're gonna get killed by a
weapon of war at a school i mean he's
talking about the real issues that the
community wants the politicians to talk
about it is it is vitally important that
our people who set policy for us in our
government because it's ours whether
it's a state or the federal government
it's ours they are they are doing the
things that the community wants and the
community needs and i think that's what
this is today from the president and
then remarks that we're going to hear
the the other thing i want to bring up
that is like what is being announced
today is a great start right like in in
the same way when they passed the health
care bill under the obama administration
that was a good start right everyone was
like oh it's got to be all or nothing
right it's got to be and and mind you
like even the healthcare bill was very
scaled down to what it ended up being
and from there republicans tried to
strip it away to what to down to be
nothing but the way that i look at this
student loan uh forgiveness is the same
way that i looked at the healthcare bill
it's meant to be a starting block to
build on right it's not meant to be like
if if we could yeah we would do it all
and be great and everyone would be happy
but i mean this is a starting block to
really take a look at the systems in
place to identify it's broken and it
needed fixing now what systemically do
we need to fix here and let's go through
and actually make amendments to this we
make it better but
if we live in this world that is it's
all or nothing it's bang or bust then we
won't move anywhere we won't progress to
something that is better from nothing
and so i think that a lot of people
really need to look at this right now
and and take off the i pay for my loans
or this or that it's like look
let me tell you 15 we're lifting
everyone up with this
let me say two things first i want to
address uh
a comment here from someone named
michael let me see if i could pull it
back up uh because this person is just a
really sad pathetic person and i think
everybody should should talk to michael
here michael said something like
you sissies are done i i i lost it here
but it's something like
read it you sissies are never gonna take
our guns and the fbi is done see this is
just somebody in like a bizarre uh weird
mag occult world like you're just not
living in reality and i feel bad for you
and i thank you for watching the maya's
touch podcast because maybe deep down
you do want to get some truth and some
facts but let's be real nobody is coming
for your guns at all all people people
just don't want kids to be shot up in
schools and if that's too much for you
then maybe you have to reevaluate your
life choices the fbi the fbi does a lot
of has done a lot of bad things
throughout history i i'll give you that
100 percent here they're going exactly
by the book and they are not injecting
politics into this whatsoever in fact
donald trump is the one injecting
politics in this to try to say well look
at how popular i am you can't prosecute
somebody as popular as me that's
injecting politics into this and what
our fbi agents are doing is first off
they gave donald trump so much slack
here they gave him so many opportunities
dozens of opportunities to hand over
these documents he lied every step of
the way his attorneys lied every step of
the way and that's on him he could have
turned these back and this couldn't have
been an issue but there's a reason why
he's stealing those documents and once
again if this was joe biden doing it if
it was barack obama doing it this is any
president doing it i hope the fbi would
do the same exact thing and i know that
they would because these are our top
secret the highest levels of
classification of these documents and i
like how you said our i like how you
said our bret you said our top secret
documents because i think that's where
the disconnect is here for these
trumpers and trump himself is he really
doesn't fundamentally understand that
the office of the presidency is ours
it's our office we get to choose who's
there for the four years and sometimes
it's two four-year terms in a row but we
get to decide about who is in our office
now we can have those are our documents
tonight there are documents that he's
taken and when he invokes executive
privilege ironically what he's also
doing there is he is saying that the
documents that he had were property of
the us government that he took so he's
actually admitting to his crimes when he
says that and he does not have executive
privilege the executive is president
biden the executive is the current power
office in our office and those documents
are our documents so he is stealing from
you uh michael if you're a real human
being but another note i wanted to read
is a quote that i saw that resonated
with me the other day somebody on
twitter um where they said voting isn't
a marriage it's public transport you're
not waiting for the one who's absolutely
perfect you're getting the bus and if
there's not one to your destination you
don't just hop on the one heading in the
opposite direction
yeah and so you know going to back to
what gabe was saying like we constantly
want to be heading in the correct
direction and democrats are constantly
trying to take us in that correct
direction and our country is so divided
and polarized in many ways but most of
our country wants to be heading in this
better direction of affordable
drug prices of people being able to get
the health care they need people being
able to pay off student loans that's the
direction where americans want to be
heading in and so when we hear a lot
about also like these polls that say you
know 80 percent of people say america is
heading in the wrong direction uh
including 75 percent of democrats
i want to know the next answer okay
who's taking us in the wrong direction
that they are scared of and inevitably i
think what you're finding is people like
if you ask me that question i'd probably
say the same thing because i see the
direction that these republicans are
taking us in the stripping of our rights
the uh ending of roe v wade things like
that and i say yes we are obviously
heading in the wrong direction because
of republicans right and so we need to
overcome that and that's what's on the
line here and we need to be the people
who are pushing us in the right
direction and you can't always be going
well i need to have the perfect person
to do this or if the policy is not 100
there right i'm not voting for them or
whatever because then guess what you are
handing a vote to the donald trumps to
the desantis's to the marjory taylor
greens you are giving them the power and
what they will do with it is they will
take us hard in the opposite direction
and then it's going to be that much
harder to get back the way that we want
to go and that's what we saw with trump
and now we're recovering from those
years which took us so far in the wrong
direction that piece by piece we are
piecing back together this country and
president biden has done it in the face
of unprecedented opposition here right
well you know the other thing that i
think he's done and again i don't toot
uh biden's horn a lot and i probably
should do it more but really honestly
he's done it in a way that has kind of
ignored
like the the the social network and the
the yelling and screaming and the noise
right like he could have gave into this
gas price thing he could have gave in to
all these other this all this other
noise that was being created by the the
right machine monst the right far right
monster that is that media machine he
could have gave into that the media
really gave him a tough time oh how is
donald trump being served a search
warrant for top secret dachshunds he's
how was that bite for bad for biden like
what the hell are you talking about like
he could play into all that he could be
tweeting about this he could be sitting
down on the toilet really rage tweeting
but he hasn't he gets up every morning
he puts on his shoes and he goes down to
our office which he knows that he's
working for us in that office and he's
doing the things that he thinks is best
for the american people now i think that
there are several things that he will
fall short on i absolutely believe that
joe biden will not do everything that he
absolutely wants to do for the american
people but i think he gets up every
morning knowing that this is democracy
he gets up every morning understanding
what is at stake not just for our
security but also for us economically
and socially like we are headed in a
direction that we don't want to go and i
am trying to give the american people
the actual
opportunity to take their country and
take their democracy to a whole another
place to to a place where equity
equality and liberty is achieved through
democracy because i believe he believes
in those core principles and that is the
difference between the vote that
happened in 2020 is that
people chose decency the bar was that
low but we actually had someone who had
the decency to care about the american
people and i think his statement today
will show that because he's done it time
and time again he's he's gotten so much
flack and he does something and he shows
his decency he shows his empathy and he
shows that he does care about our
democracy and he's really very
talented at knowing kind of how
washington works i mean well he's done
it for a long time he's done it he's
done it for a long time and you could
knock him for that and say he's a
product of washington which is off
nothing but he knows how to get [ __ ]
done in washington like he does and i
think that's showing with all the
legislation that he has been able to
pass i mean nobody thought that he would
get the inflation reduction act passed
nobody thought joe manchester i don't
mean to interrupt we're going to have
the president i think here in a second
because uh looks like they just put the
speech on the podium so i want to i want
to give every i want to give everyone a
um an idea again we're on the midas
touch network here please please follow
and subscribe to the minus touch network
here if you're if you're joining us if
you're just joining us we are going to
be covering the student loan forgiveness
plan and joe biden's remarks on that
plan um it looks like they just uh came
out with the speech in a folder and put
it on the podium i'm keeping an eye here
um so we're really watching these
remarks here as we deliver them to you i
didn't mean to cut you off right i just
wanted no no that's that's a great
update i'm really excited for president
biden to speak i think this is a this is
a big moment and it's another win and a
streak of biden wins i mean you know
dark brandon is absolutely crushing it
he is slaying the naysayers and i want
to bring also attention to this new
tweet from cap action which is a
brilliant response to
these uh republican uh comments about
you know basically pay back all your
loans no matter what the interest is
this is a bailout this is a handout uh
it's a brilliant tweet i'm not sure if
you're able to pull it up and cap action
but it's republican members give me if
you give me if you put the link in the
private chat there i can i can pull it
i'll do that for you so republican
members of congress whose ppp loans were
forgiven matt gates had 476 000 of ppp
loans forgiven marjorie taylor green had
180 000 dollars of ppp loans forgiven
greg pence mike pence's brother 79 441
forgiven vern buchanan from florida 2.8
million dollars in ppp loans forgiven
kevin hearn over 1 million forgiven
roger williams 1.43 million brett
guthrie 4.3 million ralph norman 306 k
ralph abraham 38k mike kelly 974k vicky
hartzler 451k mark wayne mullen 988 000
carol miller 3.1 million dollars in ppp
loans forgiven so you know what i do not
want to hear
one damn thing from these republicans
about people getting ten thousand
dollars in student loans forgiven
because if they're allowed to take three
plus million dollars for themselves i
think it's okay when the average
american finally gets the relief that
they need it's just so hypocritical and
it shows you really where their
interests are their interests lie with
padding their bank accounts and helping
their billionaire friends which is why
it's so rich whenever these people
pun intended uh speak out against this
sort of thing when you have people who
are constantly looking for ways to
defraud the system if if he hasn't made
a comment yet i'm sure like a guy like
rick scott will make us
here comes the president i think he's
going to be coming in here uh any minute
here let me see if i can
uh but the other the other person that
uh when you bring up the list of people
like elaine chao mitch mcconnell's wife
a recipient of pvp loans like uh you
know mitch mcconnell who is in kentucky
and relies on government aid and
assistance for for constituents
you know the guy who is willing to
criticize others for getting a handout
is silent when it comes to the loans
here's here's the first years of
universal education is not enough
and that we're going to be out competed
by the rest of the world if we don't
take action
but here's the deal
the cost of education beyond high school
has gone up significantly
the total cost to attend a public
four-year
university has tripled nearly tripled in
40 years
tripled
instead of properly funding public
colleges many states have cut back their
support we're just talking about that in
the oval many states have cut back
support for
their state universities
leaving students to pick up more of the
tab
in 50 years for 50 years pell grants
have been a key way for the federal
government to help lower income families
particularly those earning less than 60
thousand dollars a year to send their
kids to college
those pell grants used to cover eighty
percent
eighty percent of the cost of going to a
public four-year college
today
pell grants cover 30 30 about roughly 32
that's one third of the cost as opposed
to before
it matters
i remember walking up now
my dad like probably a lot of your folks
cared a lot about your education
my dad's greatest regret was that he
never got to go to college
and my dad was a very well-read man
particularly history and
but it was a great regret you always say
joey you're going to be a college man
and i'd say dad but
what does that matter i mean you can
still get fired if you're a college man
she said yeah but they can never take it
away from you they can never take your
education away
and i remember my senior year i got into
uh
one of the little ivies and i got into a
number of schools and we're trying to
get the money even with financial
assistance to be able to go there
we had four kids all of uh all of us
wanting to go to school
and um
i remember going down after a baseball
game i
went to a really good school up in
clemont delaware on the pennsylvania
border
and uh drove down to newark delaware my
dad worked at an automobile agency
and i walked in and i had my spikes and
because the reason i was going down when
your dad works an automobile agency the
great advantage you get a new car to go
to the prom or a you could use car off
the wall you think i'm joking i'm not
joking and so i went down to my 51
plymouth
uh with uh beach towels for seat covers
and uh i had my uniform on my spikes off
i ran in and the woman's name was mary
who ran the place i said mary where's
dad said he's out in the lane going into
the in the repair shop
give him my word true story
and my dad was a well-dressed refined
fella and i walked out and my dad was
pacing back and forth between the big
garage door going into the
into the uh repair shop and the door
going out of the showroom
and they looked up he said oh joey
honey i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i thought god something
happened this before cell phones so
something happened to one of my brothers
or my sister or my mom or something i
said what's the matter dad he said i
want to see the guy's name was charlie
delter who was a
vice president of the farmer's bank
which was a state-owned bank that did a
lot of the financing of people wanting
to purchase a car
so it went to charlie and asked to
borrow the money
he said
he won't lend it to me he said i'm so
ashamed
i'm so damn ashamed
you know my dad would you know
my dad was like millions of parents all
across the country
i want to help the kids to get to school
but there was just no way to be able to
do it you know
and because he believed as i do that
education is a ticket to a better life
but something jill and i kamala and doug
we we understand deeply i'm sure the
vast majority of you do as well but over
time that ticket has become too
expensive for too many americans
all all this means is the entire an
entire generation is now saddled with
unsustainable debt in exchange for an
attempt at least at a college degree
the burden is so heavy that even if you
graduate you may not have access to
middle class life that the college
degree once provided
many people many people can't qualify
for a mortgage to buy a home because the
debt they continue to carry
they uh you know they they carry is too
high they can't come up with the down
payment anyway
a lot of folks are even putting off
starting families because of the cost
and the dream of starting and earning
your own business is just way off in the
distance with the debt that's that so
many years saddled with
many of you had to leave school because
the financial strain was much too high
about a third of the borrowers have debt
but no degree
and worst of both worlds debt and no
degree
the burden is especially heavy on black
and hispanic borrowers who on average
have less family wealth to pay for it
there's no they don't own their homes to
borrow against to be able to pay for
college
and the pandemic only made things worse
but we responded aggressively to the
pandemic to minimize the economic impact
of the harm of cove and imposing on
individuals families and businesses you
all were there with recovery look we
increased unemployment benefits for
workers who were laid off
we provided loans to small businesses so
they could stay afloat and take care of
their families and their employees we
provided assistance to people to put
food on the table remember those long
lines you guys would all film of cars
decent looking cars not jalopies you
know nice cars
just waiting for a box of food to be put
in the trunk
in the united states of america
waiting for over an hour to get food in
a truck
and we provided rent and mortgage
assistance to keep people from being
evicted
and thrown out in the street
our approach to help americans who need
it the most was necessary
and it was the right thing to do and it
helped people avoid financial crisis
which helped our whole country as a
consequence of that that didn't benefit
them it benefited the whole economy our
approach is why america's economic
recovery
economic recovery was faster
and stronger than any other advanced
nation in the world
and now it's time to address the burden
of student debt in the same way
working closely with the secretary of
education he's got the hard job
you know
secretary cardona
here's what my administration is going
to do to provide more breathing room for
people so they have less burden by
student debt
and quite frankly to fix the system
itself which we came in we both
acknowledged was broken
in terms of anyway
there are three key factors what we're
going to do today
first we've made incredible progress
advancing america's economic recovery
we've wound down pandemic relief
programs like the ones on employment
insurance and small businesses
it's time we do the same thing for
student
loans
student loan payments pause is going to
end
it's going to end december 30 i'm
extending to december 31st
2022 and it's going to end at that time
it's time for the payments to resume
second
my campaign for president i made a
commitment i made a comment that would
provide student debt relief
and i'm honoring that commitment today
using the authority congress grant at
the department of education
we will forgive
ten thousand dollars in outstanding
federal student loans
in addition
students who come from low-income
families which allowed them to qualify
to receive a pell grant
will have their debt reduced twenty
thousand dollars
both of these targeted actions are for
families who need it the most
working and middle class people hit
especially hard during the pandemic
making under
125 000 a year you make more than that
you don't qualify
no high income individual or high income
household
on top of the five percent in the top
five percent of incomes by the way
will benefit from this action period
in fact about ninety percent of the end
of the the eligible beneficiaries make
under seventy five thousand dollars a
family
here's what that means
if you make under 125 000 you get ten
thousand dollars knocked off your
student debt
if you make under 125 000 a year and you
received a pell grant
you'll get an additional ten thousand
dollars knocked off that total for a
total of twenty thousand dollar relief
95 of the borrowers can benefit from
these actions
that's
43 million people
of the 43 million
over 60 percent of pell grant recipients
that's 27 million people who will get 20
000 in debt relief
nearly 45 can have their student debt
fully cancelled
that's 20 million people who can start
getting on with their lives
all this means people can start
finally crawl out from under that
mountain of debt
to get on top of their rent in their
utilities
to finally think about buying a home or
starting a family or starting a business
and by the way
when this happens the whole economy is
better off
in the coming weeks the department of
education will lay out in detail
a short and simple form to apply for
this relief
along with information when this
application process opens
by resuming student loan payments at the
same time as we provide targeted relief
we're taking an economically responsible
course
as a consequence
about 50 billion a year will start
coming back into the treasury because
the resumption of debt
independent experts agree that these
actions taken together
will provide real benefits for families
without meaningful effect on inflation
let's be clear i hear it all the time
how do we pay for it
we pay for it by what we've done
last year we cut the deficit by more
than 350
billion dollars
this year we're on track to cut it by
more than 1.7 trillion by the end of
this fiscal year
the single largest deficit reduction in
the single year in the history of
america
and the inflation reduction accident cut
it by another 300 billion over the next
decade because medicare will be paying
less for prescription drugs
and over a trillion dollars we add it
out for the next two decades
the point
is this
there is plenty of deficit reduction to
pay for the program's cumulative
definitions play for the programs many
times over
i will never apologize ever helping
americans working working america's
middle class
especially not to the same folks who
voted for a two trillion dollar tax cut
that mainly benefited the wealthiest
americans and the biggest corporations
that slowed the economy didn't do a lot
for an economic growth and wasn't paid
for
and racked up this enormous deficit just
as we've never apologized when the
federal government forgave almost every
single cent
of over 700 billion dollars in loans to
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses across the across america
during the pandemic
no one complained
that those loans caused inflation
a lot of these folks in small businesses
are working in middle class families
they needed help it was the right thing
to do
so the outrage over helping working
people
with student with student loans i think
is just simply wrong dead wrong
third thing
we're fixing the student loan program
system itself
we've talked about this at len this is
really important
we're proposing to make what's called an
income driven repayment plan simple and
fair and here's how
no one with an undergraduate loan today
or in the future whether for community
college or four-year college will have
to pay more than five percent
of their discretionary income
to repay their loan
that's income after you pay the
necessities like housing food and the
like
you currently pay 10 percent
we're cutting that in half to 5
and after you pay your loan for 20 years
your obligation will be fulfilled if it
hadn't already been fulfilled meaning
you won't have to pay any more period
and borrows who original balance was
less than 12 000
many of whom are community college
students
will be done paying just after 10 years
these changes will save more than a
thousand dollars a year on average for
the borrower
it's a game changer
we're also fixing what's called and this
has been the bane of
driving me crazy when i was out of
office
the public service loan forgiveness
program
now this program forgives student loans
to encourage those students who have
those loans if they go and do public
service
think of the millions who are
public school teachers
local police officers
workers at local charities
members of the military in the national
guard
and so many more think of the folks who
work for federal state local tribal
governments keeping essential services
going responding to natural disasters
all those firefighters and cops
the program is designed so that if you
serve in one of these jobs
and we'll be able to list those and that
you'll be able to accurately assess
whether you do and make your loan
payments for 10 years even if it's not
consecutive years
your remaining balance will be
completely forgiven
it's a great idea but the program's a
mess
it's so inefficient and complicated too
many people just give up
think if a service member defers their
student loan payment while they're
deployed
the system is so restrictive that their
active duty service didn't count as
public service
and the loan isn't forgiven as promised
it's outrageous
well the man to my left is going to fix
it the department of education has
recently proposed changes that will make
this program work better
and over the long term much better
and now the department
issues emergency temporary changes to
retroactively credit public service
so accounts
and loans are forgiven
since i've been in office more than 175
000 teachers
nurses
police officers have been able to get
over 10 billion in loan forgiveness so
far through this program
but this opportunity expires on october
31st 2022
so my message to all servants
all public servants all those who are
the ones that are volunteering
is
out with student debt
to go here's what you want if you if
you're worried about how to do it
go to
pslf.gov
before october 31st to see if you
qualify for public service to student
loan forgiveness
this is another game changer and we're
going to have people who are there to
help get you help help direct you and
work your work through the process
and one more big change we're making to
the system is we're holding colleges
accountable for jacking up costs without
delivering value to students
we've all heard of those schools luring
students with a promise of big paychecks
when they graduate
only to watch these students be ripped
off and left with mountains of debt
and my process looked the other way for
some reason with good reason
to do anything about this fraud
my administration is taking it on for
example
the department of education works with
private education associations to
accredited college to accredit colleges
and universities so they can receive
federal aid
well last week the department of
education
fired a college accreditor that allowed
colleges like itt and corinthian to
defraud borrowers
and combined with our emergency actions
the public service forgiveness program
and other acts we've taken we've been
able to cancel more than 32 billion
dollars in student debt
for 1.6 million bars including those
defrauded by these bad acting schools
our goal is to shine a light on the
worst actors so students can avoid these
dead traps
now
i understand not everyone every not
everything i'm announcing today is going
to make everybody happy
something is too much
i find it interesting how
some of my republican friends who voted
for those tax cuts and others think
that we shouldn't be helping these folks
something is too little
but i believe my plan is responsible and
fair
it focuses the benefit on middle class
and working families
it helps both current and future
borrowers
and will fix a badly broken system
these actions build on my
administration's effort to make college
more affordable in the first place
it includes unprecedented investments
nearly 6 billion in historic black
colleges universities
much of which is focused on pandemic
relief to help students
cover tuition
and other costs so they can stay in
school
and i must be honest with you i'm going
to continue to fight for doubling the
pell grants i didn't get that done this
time
let me say it again
12 years of universal education is not
enough
i'm going to continue to work for
universal pre-k
for every three and four-year-old
and universal community college for
education beyond high school
let me close this
i ran for office to grow the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
because when we do that everybody does
better everybody does well
the wealthy do very well the poor have a
way up and the middle class can have
breathing room
and that's going to help america win the
economic competition of the 21st century
because much of my time is spent how do
we remain the most competitive nation in
the world
with the strongest economy in the world
with the greatest opportunities in the
world
that's what today's announcement is
about it's about opportunity
it's about giving people a fair shot
it's about
the one word america can be defined by
possibilities
it's all about providing possibilities
we're going to have a lot more to say
about this there's a lot of material
that's going to be put out as to how
this is being implemented and i want to
thank you all and god bless you all
thank you thank you thank you mr
president how much advanced knowledge
did you have so there we have the
president united states
he's going to be uh taking some
questions here so we're going to listen
to a few oh no he's not going to take
questions he's going to
walk out here and not take any more
questions especially when it has to
pertain to do with
mar-a-lago
um gabe there's a few notes that i want
to talk about here as we
as we
exit here from the press conference
about student known student debt relief
um he said bottom up and middle out
that's just what we were talking about
on our show earlier now bottom up and
middle out
he really does seem concerned with the
american people that seems to be at the
forefront of his mind when he's
developing this program i want i want to
uh give you a contrast here of something
he talked about the department of
education because all this comes from
the department of education
the republican party the the cue and
honors the gqp
the america first fascist who are
running around um having nazi rallies
everywhere talking about destroying our
democracy because they want to end it
they want to abolish is their word the
department of education right um here uh
here
president biden lays out a third of the
debt that is actually out there that
this is going to affect um
people have no degree so they went and
they they took out debt with no degree
uh also the pell grants aren't just for
low-income folks they are also for for
people coming out of high school they
are also low-income folks who are trying
to enter back into an economy where they
can have a degree so they they get out
of high school they do uh they have a
job for a long time they have a family
and they're trying to one-up themselves
in the economy trying to do better in
the economy by going and get getting a
degree so those people actually receive
pell grants as we mentioned on our show
the tony michael podcast before 43
million the president said
60 of those pell grants
um so 43 million people actually have
student debt in this country but 60
that that is a huge number of people who
are receiving pell grants meaning that
they don't really have the funds to
afford to go to college in this modern
day that's what that that's what that is
and
and i think the important thing to
remember here is that when people say
like oh you know you should be able to
pay back your student loan that you took
out okay
the comparison that is made from those
people like the gop right you've got jim
jordan making these statements the thing
to keep in mind is that the cost of
education
was significantly less than what it is
now
and again it has exponentially risen
over the rate of inflation year over
year over year over year especially for
these private institutions
so that is something to remember that
like oh well you just paid off well it's
not it's not the same as if you know
years ago
you know when we were in school or our
parents were in school or their parents
were in school like the cost of
education has exponentially grown over
the rate of inflation
in this country and it has made it more
and more difficult for people to afford
and then pay off those loans especially
as interest rates rise well that's
that's an important point because the
president also said in this program that
the the actual um maximum amount that
you will pay for your loan each year
is going to go from 10 of your
discretionary income which means after
your expenses your mortgage and all that
kind of stuff um
we'll go from 10 to 5 so it's going to
be cut in half so it's not just going to
be loan forgiveness yeah this program is
just not loan forgiveness in an amount
because 45
of the loans that are out there
will be gone because of this program
so they won't have to be saddled with
that burden of knowing that debt is
there
but the most important factor is not
only will
all those people be able to now use that
money in other ways in our economy which
will grow our economy because that's how
economics work here in a in a liberal
democracy where we we we practice
capitalism but also
the people who are still going to be
paying payments this is important yeah
people who are still going to be paying
towards the student loans are going to
have some of their payments cut in half
so that leaves more discretionary
spending to go back into our economy to
help the american people and i want to
also mention one other thing that i
think is very impressive with this
program
is the 10-year 20-year rule
because biden also mentioned that
they want to implement this 10-year
20-year gone rule which means if you pay
on your student loans for 20 years no
matter how long you pay for it it
doesn't matter it's gone it's gone at
that point you paid 20 years of your
life towards
five percent and i think that's where
why he said it there because he he kind
of mentioned this after the five percent
rule so going from ten percent to five
percent what the america what joe
biden's saying to the american people i
think
the president united states is saying i
think if you pay
five percent of your discretionary
income
every year towards your education
that should be enough to say that you've
done your you've done and paid your debt
for that education and i think that's
very important when he's talking to the
american people saying these things
yeah no i think it i think it is
incredibly important you know again
going back to this
um you know bottom up and middle out
right like you have to be looking
forward how to help
uh the american people right the middle
class and those who are
in the lower class area like you have to
be looking out for those people because
those are the people
that are working working in this economy
right generating uh the the stimulation
within the economy those are the people
that matter and those are the people
that we should be looking out for in any
way that we can you know just because
it's 10 to 20k right now from you know
10 for private and 20 for pell grants
like he even said there is more that i
want to do but we need to remember the
most important thing out of all of this
not only because going from 10 to 5 is a
big [ __ ] deal okay i'll just say that
that is that is no that is no small
thing and taking that in addition to the
10 to 20k in loan forgiveness
these are things that will greatly help
people that are struggling because the
democrats joe biden
are actually caring for the american
people despite what republicans say oh
we'll get to it we'll do it and they
never do
they will do whatever they can to screw
over the constituents that have voted
them into office that they elected to
protect them right they elected these
people to protect them and then on the
other side you've got these republicans
that say
well you know
pull yourself up by your bootstraps and
figure it out right no sort of aid no
sort of assistance no sort of safety net
to make sure that we don't fail
as a country
and that is what joe biden and the
democrats have done even in this last
month or so of passing these different
acts they are investing and betting on
america they are investing and betting
on the american people to say look we
know times trust incredibly tough
and we want to help you so that you can
make this country
exactly what we have dreamt it to be
and then
it's it's it's that easy to look at the
party that is helping and doing
something to help us as americans and
the party that it just sits by and says
well they want to abolish the department
of education right
yeah well we talked about it today on
our show and i i i don't wanna i don't
wanna give too much a shameless blood
but please go over to our channel the
tony michaels podcast and follow us we
have a show every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and we
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page so go over to our youtube channel
the tony michaels podcast and follow us
there but today on our show we talked
about the the
stark
historical contrast today where the
president united states is coming out
and delivering yet again for the
american people as he says bottom up
middle out and then we have the former
guy
the former guy down at the wall down at
the the the fake white house at
mar-a-lago hiding documents a judge says
no this order's [ __ ] you're in the
wrong court it looks like it's written
in crown he's he's yelling and screaming
apparently and his staff and his list i
want my documents back
he says
my documents and he doesn't understand
that those are our documents it's our
office it's our government it's ours the
people it's ours we voted it's ours and
i think
the stark contrast here to today of the
president united states joe biden coming
out and delivering again once again for
the american people even at the calls
that it he would not be able to do it
he's done it again
time and time again he's delivered he
delivered today on student loan debt for
all the people who were naysayers and
some of them on the left and we'll talk
about that in a second
but the stark contrast
that joe biden understands that that
office of the presidency is the american
people's office
and he is there to put his shoes on and
get up every morning to work for the
american people regardless of what state
they live in what county who they voted
for what their ideology is what their
religion is
he doesn't care he's there to make sure
that he gives the best opportunity and
the most trust to the american people to
do what's right for america and give
them that opportunity to prove it now i
want to go to the people who are
naysayers because we've seen a lot of
this all or nothing stuff as well today
it's not just the right wing he was like
abolish the department of education
and see where that gets you like yeah we
want to all be really dumb in this
country is what we want to do
but we see the naysayers on the other
side who are saying
all or nothing this isn't enough this
isn't enough let me remind everyone
again
let me remind everyone again who say
this is not enough
45
percent now again this is all loans
because this this is important this is
super important none of this benefit
will go to people who make 125 000 or
more what joe biden is saying is if you
can afford your student loans we're
going to make you pay them and that
starts at the end of this year we are
not pausing payments anymore from now on
you have to pay because we're doing this
program and if you make over a certain
amount of money you will you won't
benefit from this you have enough money
to do this
so having said that all the people who
can't afford their loans
45
of all loans outstanding are going to be
gone they're going to be wiped off the
books i think a lot of people who are
the oh all or nothing don't understand
that so many people are going to have
all their student don't debt gone it's
gone it it is gone it is paying for
people's student debt because so many
people i mean here a third of all the
debt outstanding people don't even have
degrees it's like me i i dropped out of
college twice gabe i had loans each time
and i had to pay back those loans now i
don't begrudge people who still have
loan debt and i don't say oh well they
don't deserve it because i didn't get it
i mean i benefited from those few those
federal student loan programs to get the
college education that i still don't
have a degree for right but that's the
point here is that everyone all the
naysayers all the all or nothing you
know this is like uh tyt young turk
stuff nina turner stuff um they say all
or nothing it's not enough but it but it
if you look at what is actually going to
do yeah it really is a lot it's a lot
further it'll make a huge impact 45 of
all loans are gone and that is the most
important and it's affecting the lowest
income of people in this country the
people who trade their labor they count
on getting these educations to go from
making minimum wage to actually having a
livable wage in this country right which
is another thing we need to tackle but
right now this is a step towards that
direction because
half half
excuse me the amount that you're going
to pay of your discretionary income for
the student loan is now cut in half if
you still have a student loan lab you're
only going to have to pay for 20 years
um
now i i i am always skeptical of a
government program like this in the info
the implementation of it so we'll see
what that rollout looks like
but hopefully hopefully it's pretty easy
when 45 percent of the debt is just gone
i think that and i just want to
reiterate like the idea that
that it's all or nothing right it's this
or bust i think it's a very
ignorant way and naive way to look at
how we are progressing in advancing us
as uh
as as the united states right we have a
problem that problem is our higher
education system it is not only how much
we have to pay for it but what we are
getting out of it as a result and the
private institutions that can continue
to increase their price year over year
of year not and that's not even
including the for-profit institutions
like uh itt or um
the other uh for-profit uh institutions
that you can take online or you know the
career colleges or what have you the
ones that have been you know uh caught a
fraud or you know um cheating students
or whatever it might be like
i i forget what the number was 20 30
billion i forget which one he said that
they have already forgiven because of
institutions like this
um just the this past year but you you
you look at this and say like
this all or nothing
type of way of thinking is is in is is
incredibly flawed and we need to stop
and think about how this is actually
benefiting
45
or more people depending on where you
fall on the spectrum in terms of the
loans right the idea that you have to
stop and say well if i can get it no one
should get it i think that is very
ignorant yeah sure it is unfortunate
that you can't get the assistance that
you want look i was the recipient of of
pell grant loans
private loans and the the government
issued pell grant loans i paid off i'm
not upset i'm not
uh uh completely um
just
uh overwhelmed in hatred toward the idea
that this was done for other people
right i am grateful and i mean it helps
us all happy yeah
we talked about that in our rising tide
lifts all boats right the idea that we
can help everyone right helping yeah
it's the economy this is going to be
good for the economy which is good for
the american people um and and that is
the point going forward now rona
mcdaniel uh brought up some kind of poll
it seemed uh a good again polls these
days are way the [ __ ] off they're
they're absolutely ridiculous most of
them are completely wrong we talked
about it on our show several times um
but
this poll that 59 of americans now
let me be clear not economists americans
think that this student debt relief is
going to cause inflation like what in
the hell are you talking about how in
the world is people having less
cost in their discretionary spending
going to cause inflation number one
number two
i want to go back to um the pell grant
thing because i think that is important
when rona mcdaniel is trying to make her
statement because she's trying to speak
to average americans because everyone
has student loan debt whether you're a
trump supporter a binding supporter
someone who doesn't really can even pay
attention to politics you probably have
some student loan debt or know someone
or someone in your family or affects you
in some way
back to the pell grant thing um because
i think a lot of people want to make
sure community college and stuff is um
is is free and i think we should work in
that direction but this actually works
in that direction if you think about it
because if you have pell grants that
20-year rule actually turns to 10 years
which most pell grants
are done at community colleges and that
reason why is because they are lower
income people so they can't afford to
move halfway across the country they
can't afford to move to a big city
and afford to live in a big city to go
to a big university they have to utilize
community colleges and tech schools to
do that and i think that's important
when you talk about we're stepping from
they have to pay back all their student
loan debt to five percent of their
discretionary income cutting that in
half from 10
and then all they'll have to pay if they
receive pell grants is 10 years and
they're done so yes we're not quite
where we'd like to be with community
colleges because i really do think pell
grants and community colleges the grant
should just be your education not the
money right right and even but we're
stepping in that direction and even
biden said during the campaign trail he
said i wish for community college to be
something that is free like the idea
that you have to pay for community
college and again we talked about our
show is like you know states have
certain rules in place in terms of uh of
you know
if those costs are covered right that's
on a state level but on a federal level
is something inherently different right
something that republicans won't want
because they don't want people you know
they don't want educated people they
don't want people to get the ability to
use their degree to advance their career
and get a livable wage right this is
something that republicans don't want
one is the very opposite comparison of
what joe biden is advocating for and
trying to push for and even said
i didn't get everything that i wanted
right i believe in education for three
and four-year-olds and i believe in
continuing education i believe that you
should have the ability
to go to where you want to go and not
have to pay out of the ass
for these costs right and and not have
to because the other thing too is we
talked about with brett earlier on the
show is like the actual the the fact of
getting a loan of 50 000 and by the end
of that loan repayment period 20 30
years whatever it might be you're paying
150 000 in total like principal on
interest or interest on principal like
that idea is insane that you're like
now you have to say
take this loan for 50k but by the end of
it what we don't tell you
is that if you pay the interest on all
these things for the longest amount of
time you're actually paying 2x or 3x or
whatever it might be based on what you
originally borrowed to get that
education forward
so like that is broken and i and i just
want to point out the system the higher
education system and how we pay for it
right it is broken it is inherently
broken it does need to be fixed but
these small changes are going to help
people along the way right so step in
that right direction like we said
earlier and i think i think as we
reflect here because thank you for
joining us for the special coverage here
on the midas touch network and sticking
around on our show
we proved that we can do three and a
half hours now our audience is gonna be
like hey hey you've done three and a
half hours because you know we do two
hours every single week day monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from the midas
touch facebook page so don't forget to
go over and follow our channel over on
youtube the tony michaels podcast but
also follow the midas touch network here
for all your special reports that we
bring to you okay we're gonna have these
hearings coming up uh you know what
hearings i'm talking about the january
6th select hearings and we'll be airing
live here on the midas touch network
we'll be covering those hearings as they
announce them right so don't go anywhere
make sure you stay tuned set the set the
bell notification because we have all
kinds of breaking news stories coming to
you from the midas touch network and all
the personalities and characters we have
over here we got ben mizellas jordy
mizellis when he gets better we got
texas paul coach d we got tennessee
brando we got michael cohen
the list goes on and on and on over here
and i i'm so happy to be part of this
network to deliver you guys
pro-democracy speech because i think
that is the most important thing that we
can do is deliver pro-democracy speech
to to the people and to you and give you
truth of what our democracy is and not
do this all or nothing thing
but please do us the favor please follow
the minus touch network now don't forget
to hit that bell notification and also
go over to my channel the tony michaels
podcast follow me and gabe every single
weekday
eastern
nine
uh excuse me new easter eleven eleven
central nine pacific it's been three and
a half hours yeah for three and a half
hours
so don't don't forget to go over and
follow us there and please watch us
every single weekday if you miss it
don't worry you can download the tony
michaels podcast on apple spotify google
wherever you get your podcast and i'm
sure i'm sure midas touch will probably
put this somewhere for you guys to see
but you can always come back to the
youtube channel if you want to refer
back to it a great conversation thanks
for sticking around gabe and thank you
brett my zealous i know you probably
he's probably out there somewhere
listening thank you for joining us and
giving us commentary on the front end
and we know at our show at our show we
have a great uh outro and because this
is still part of our show sort of i
think we should be
don't you think we should use our outro
because to all the audience out there on
a minus touch network we surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends every single
weekday in the [ __ ] list roundup so
don't miss our show don't miss the [ __ ]
list roundup when we surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends to hold these
fascists accountable but more than that
make sure you're getting that
pro-democracy speech that is so missed
in the media today
until tomorrow when you join us because
i know you will noon eastern 11th
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch and simulcasting from the midas
touch facebook page until then
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speech